this isn't what Imad had in mind for
himself his studies at Khartoum
University have been put on hold since
the war started in Sudan in April now he
makes ends meet by selling food the
universities have closed indefinitely
since 2019 universities have been under
the pressure of political unrest then
the Revolution and most recently the
ongoing War our future as students is
filled with doubt
Imad isn't the only one facing an
uncertain future the academic journey of
more than one million undergraduates has
come to a halt after universities close
their doors thousands of academic
archives and student files in many
academic institutions have also been
destroyed or stolen the ministry of
higher education Justified the decision
to close them saying they've turned into
shelters for the displaced
this decision was built on solid reasons
the premises had been transformed to a
shelter for those affected by the war
and difficulty of movement within the
country's provinces is another reason
for the closure
the government is no longer able to
afford to pay salaries to University
staff
the losses suffered by academic
institutions in Sudan are estimated to
be around 3 billion dollars many have
been damaged in the fighting 60 of
universities and schools are reported to
have been destroyed ruined too at least
for now the dreams and academic future
of hundreds of thousands of students
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera